عائله بلفور والمعروفه في نيويورك بكونها
من اثرياء صناعه النفط الامريكيه دائما ما
تقع في فخذ اكبر قصص الاحتيالي والافلاس
في امريكا بحسب ما يكشف تقرير لوكاله في
البدايه وقعت في فخر انوان شركه الطاقه
الامريكيه التي افلست في اشهر فضيحه
احتلال المحاسبي في التاريخ ونظر
لعلاقاتها المتشابكه مع ايرون تعرضت لخاله
بملياردولار عندما افلست عام 2001 وبعد
السبع سنوات فقط وقعت عائله بالفعل مره
اخرى
لكن هذه المره كانت اذكى قليلا اذا انها
سحبت ثمانيه وعشرين مليون دولار من شركه
مجددا في مصائب شركه
اف تي اكس على مراحل في عام 20 واحد و20
واوائل 20 22 اضافه الى الاستثمار في
الاعمال التجاريه لبورصه العملات المشفره
في الولايات المتحده في حسب ما ذكر